[Music]
okay
what's up mkbhd here so this is uh sort
of a everyday
carry what's in my bag what's on my
daily driver tech type video i've done
these in the past and a lot of you kept
asking when am i going to do another one
when am i going to do the 2022 update
version because i hadn't done one in
like a year honestly i think most of the
stuff that i'm using is very similar to
the last one but there are some small
upgrades so i'm going to show you what
those upgrades are that i personally use
anyway and i'm going to show you what's
on my devices so this is the backpack
this is the peak design everyday carry
20 liter so there's a 30 liter also
that's pretty massive and great for
travel but this is just for everyday i
definitely fit everything i need into
this backpack i've tried other bags in
the past different shapes different
layouts this is the one i always come
back to and as you can tell it's a
little bit different from any of the
ones you'll find on their website
because it's black with this red
stitching
there's a
some red stitching on the inside here
you can't get that from them there's
also
an mkbhd patch at the bottom it's the
mkbhd edition of the bag that only i and
some people here at the studio have but
really it's designed uh to be a
photography bag it has zippers along the
side so you can
turn it sideways and open it like that
if you want to um it's my
matte black water bottle stay hydrated
people got this as a gift for my family
on christmas but the rest of the stuff
in here
is mostly just everyday carry stuff i'm
going to start at the top
and that's the back compartment love the
way this bag is laid out
but here is the laptop of choice which
is the 16-inch m1 max macbook pro
i reviewed the thing i've talked about
it i love it clearly i went with the
16-inch because for the first time i am
actually
editing videos
away from my desk like i've taken this
home edited videos
on a couch
at a table just random other places
which is crazy
the 14 inch screen it's a great laptop
it's just a little too small so this is
the
the laptop i've actually edited videos
on so then the backpack up top here has
a bunch of other small uh pockets got a
microfiber in here and i just realized i
also still have from last time the uh sd
card reader but since this hat
i don't
don't need that uh but that's it for the
top so then there's this buckle at the
top that lets you get into the top
section there's three sections so up top
is the stuff i use the most
magsafe charger for the laptop of course
and these are the headphones that i've
traveled a lot with so anytime i travel
i typically need
noise cancelling and wireless that's the
ideal go to and so airpods max pair with
the whole ecosystem of alpha products of
course and they're in space gray so then
i also have my car keys
and other keys which have air tags on
them and then two more things
uh the body cap for the canon r5 which
is a bit of a spoiler alert to what's in
the bag and then uh there's a webcam
this is called the opel c1
uh disclaimer i'm an investor in this
company and i've been checking this out
for a little while now but i really
believe in it and this is just a webcam
that they've made for the amount of
video calls that we're on lately i tend
to get a lot of use out of that thing so
that's in my backpack and that's it
now i'm going to go the bottom section
this is what you do in a photographer
bag ready
just like that
and you can get in the side so as a
photographer bag you've got photographer
things i don't always carry this with me
but when i do carry a camera on the go i
typically will take canon's r5 i also
traveled with this exact same bag when i
went to shoot the mr beast video or for
a couple other shoots where i know i'm
doing a lot of videos i've taken the
sony a1 but for everyday stuff where i
like take a lot of photos
canon r5 with the 15 to 35 is my go-to a
lot of first-person shots with
wide-angle stuff and then last but not
least at the bottom here there's a bunch
of uh
like charging related stuff spread out
the rest of this backpack so i've got
two cables one is my usbc to lightning
cable
and then the other is actually this is
super cool that i just found recently
this is a usbc cable and there's a
little display
on the end of the cable and when you
plug something in that starts drawing
power this display lights up with the
exact wattage that that thing is drawing
so it's kind of a nice little indicator
of how much power you're getting out of
your wall brick which is pretty cool
didn't think i would care that much
about that sort of thing but i like it a
lot and this is the wall brick for usb-c
but that's just
this is just like the classic one that's
built in that apple will give you i have
over here
in this pocket a slim one this is made
by realme i don't even know if they sell
it i'll try to link everything below
that is on sale if you want to pick up
any of this stuff but it's a it's a dart
charger and i think it's about 50 watts
and uh it's a slim charger so you can
just plug it into the wall just like
that usb c at the bottom and so anytime
i'm traveling at a hotel or any place i
just need to plug something in
boom boom
charged otherwise over here i've got my
apple watch charger and this is the sad
part that they haven't made a new
version of magsafe duo that supports the
apple watch series 7's faster charging
so sadly i also carry
the uh
the faster metal puck charger if i
actually need to charge faster
this is all nerdy stuff it probably
doesn't matter for most people but
apple watch chargers then on the other
side
uh just some pens i typically don't
write things with pens very often but if
i need to sign something or write a
check or whatever that's easy
and then down here
oh yes
my adapter
my lightning to headphone jack adapter
that i still have
that's it
that's it for the bag it's empty and
that's all i really typically ever carry
again like i said camera is in there
sometimes isn't there other times
everything else is always in the bag but
i've got pockets too
let's do the pockets
okay
three pockets actually
so as far as everyday carry is concerned
i do have a back pocket and that's where
i keep my wallet which is this little
guy pretty simple it is a trove wallet
so i'll link this below although this is
again an mkbhd
carbon blacked out edition which is
pretty sick although
the whole
right side up thing i feel like this
is right side up but all the text
has this being right side up
map like everything anyway but inside it
i don't carry much i clearly don't carry
a lot in my wallet i don't have cash but
this is a dbrand skinned
key card to get into the studio very
useful to have and then this is just a
little backup key
to get into the car which actually uses
the phone and a bluetooth signal as the
key so in case my phone's dead or
something like that
or it's bugging out which that happens
sometimes too so that's the wallet and
then
two
daily driver smartphones i've told this
story before but i pretty much always
carry
an android phone and an iphone one in
each pocket it's always the android
phone on the right side and the iphone
on the left side and that's just because
i'm always in both worlds both
ecosystems i'm always testing both
things now the iphone has the most
continuity because it only changes
once or twice a year when i'm testing
the new iphones but i'm carrying an
iphone 13 pro not the pro max actually i
downsized so this is the one terabyte
space gray version though i found that
with the amount of prores video that i
shoot on this thing it helps i shot the
whole riving video on this phone so i'll
go over the setup on the iphone in a
second but i'm gonna start with the
android phone which at the moment
is the pixel 6 pro it's been a couple
months now this phone
it's fine but it's definitely getting
more buggy than when it started which is
really odd and annoying so i don't know
this has happened with pixels before but
as i fire it up this is the the setup
that uh you're probably so used to
seeing i've had this wallpaper for a
while i've had roughly this set up on
the phones for a while but i'm going to
give some shout outs to some of my
favorite things i'm doing on the phone
so it's got the weather wedgie in the
middle that's cool it seems to really
want to go to 60 hertz all the time even
though i have let's see i have 120 hertz
turned on yep still on which is kind of
annoying but
the apps are phone messaging tesla
flamingo i have the flamingo for twitter
app still on my android phones because
it's a twitter app that i really like
that ran out of tokens and is only
available to sign in for people who
already have a token on their twitter
account
so most people don't use flamingo for
twitter i use the regular twitter app
for notifications but i use flamingo
just because it's clean and looks great
for
scrolling around and just reading tweets
then i have my favorite app
i think of the entire year which is my
to do app it's called tick tick and i
feel like these really good to do apps
don't get enough credit i mean i i'm
doing a lot of things i'm trying to keep
track of a lot of different
simultaneous and parallel projects and
having a single place to put all that
information is super helpful for me so i
have it all divided and organized in
here and i've tried pretty much every
to-do list app that's out um and i found
tiktik is the best at least it's my
favorite i really like it the ui is
great the features are great it also has
a focus planner it has a pomodoro timer
it's got a whole bunch of extra stuff
you might find useful
definitely check out tiktik and then
above that i have a bunch of my most
recently used or frequently used apps
relay pro for reddit
you can get any number of different
reddit apps but i've just gotten really
used to relay pro which is great
instagram spotify youtube studio app and
then four of my most used google apps
which are youtube google drive the gmail
stock app i think is good and google
photos
uh then over here i've got a calendar
widget i'm gonna try to link that one
because it's really good
ways for navigation it's not pretty but
it's very functional
yahoo fantasy and pocketcast is my
pocket podcast app of choice then google
keep for just remembering jotting down
random notes and stuff like that and
slack which we use here at the studio
and then i just have like a
miscellaneous fitness page over here
tempo if you've heard of the tempo like
home gym
that's the app that lets you plan things
with it and google fit
but that's basically the most used stuff
on my android phone i mean here's the
entire app list
nothing too dramatic i don't have
actually that many apps and a lot of
these like annoying apps like my fios or
my att i wish i didn't have to have
those apps but they tend to be like the
most useful way to interact with these
services so
i have them but yeah that's
that's the world of my android phone at
the moment
this phone will probably change in a
week or two i don't stick with
one android phone usually for more than
about a month because i'm constantly
actually using and putting my sim card
into the next phone i'm testing
but the phone that stays constant in the
left pocket at least
with only maybe one or two changes a
year is the iphone
and so this is my iphone setup a lot of
overlap because i use a lot of the same
services
but in the iphone world there's a lot of
stuff like the copilot app which is a
finance tracking app that i
love and use on the iphone
the iphone camera app of course i've got
a tick tick widget up here and a tick
tick shortcut at the bottom because i
think it's great
um but also things like instagram dark
sky god
i hate that they took dark sky away from
android apple bought the dark sky app
and now the best weather app in the
world
is iphone only sadly
but it's really good so i keep that here
and i use it a lot tweetbot for twitter
the twitter app or the tesla app for
opening and closing the car door things
like that um we have to use a
third-party app for
group fitness challenges at the studio
so the challenges app does exactly that
hopefully someday apple can build that
in so anyone with an apple watch can
join a group competition that'd be cool
yeah weather widget nothing too crazy
here and then this is uh
that app library screen i do have among
us on my phone
i have this at what's this called again
hemisphere probably my favorite game
it's really good for just burning time
on the plane where basically you start
off as this orb and you go around and
you basically just try to absorb every
orb that's smaller than you pretty
classic
uh just become the biggest
eject move over
move over
you get the idea it's really addicting
though i've gotten
a lot of
hours sunken into this app um but yeah
the chipotle
app good stuff
uh the google home app
no surprises there
and that's what's on my two phones that
i'm carrying with me on this exact date
in january of 2022.
so yeah that's pretty much it you guys
asked for it so now you have it maybe
leave any suggestions you guys have for
good apps or good widgets or things that
i'm missing out on i love tick tick i'm
just gonna i'm gonna link as many of the
things i talked about in this video as
possible below so you can see them but
if anything else
is uh deserving to be on my radar let me
know
okay that's it thanks for watching
see you guys in the next one
peace
you